This is a very interesting point that
I've never heard before. He says in the
Quran where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
speaks of a relationship between a man
and a woman, he's never spoken about
somewhere.
This is one video. If you care about the
more than skip it by one donation,
you're going to help 1.8 million people
in need. 551,000 people who have been
fed through the emergency food aid. You
are going to be sponsoring 4,200
orphans. You will be helping 250,000
people in Gaza. You'll be helping
123,000 people to be fed through our
Kmani program. You will help feed
551,000
people through the emergency food aid.
56 massages that are going to be built
around the world and 74,000 given clean
safe water. That's why we want to keep
one Umar 100% donation policy. And in
order for us to keep 100, we need you to
help us by supporting this fund so that
all of the stuff that I mentioned, you
get the reward for every single one of
them is far more important than the
dunya. and you will see every penny that
you give on your Makyama. The decision
is yours. The link is there. Donate now.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends, I
think this video is one of the most
important videos I can bring to you
guys. Anyone that is on the verge of
divorcing their spouse, be it obviously
the husband has a right to divorce, but
or if it's a sisters going to uh go down
the route of asking holla or getting a
fist by going to a scholar. Before you
guys go anywhere near that, please watch
this because this is such an important
video. Subhan Allah that I have ever
done. And like I said before guys, you
know how I feel about divorce. You know
how I feel about Subhan Allah not
encouraging divorce and unless it's the
last resort. And subhan Allah um
brothers and sisters the video that I'm
going to show you blew my mind like when
I saw I was like that is so deep and I
had to share it with you guys. Look at
what
Shakiri says. Okay. And this is brother
Ibrahim Ibrahim Ming translating. I
never thought the Quran says this. If
you are married to an abuser,
psychological abuse or physical abuse,
these are both abuse. Some even say
psychological abuse is worse than
physical abuse because it has longerterm
effects on an individual like a bruise
can recover of course but psychological
abuse that could be caused by that
bruise or verbal abuse. These are all
things that are unacceptable and in
Islam it is unacceptable. Alhamdulillah
the prophetam the best man to walk this
earth never laid a hand on his uh wife.
Subhan Allah. So listen to this
carefully guys and I'm going to give you
some evidences from the Quran because
when you go to the Quran and I was like
wow I looked at the verses nowhere does
it tell you to have patience with an
abuser. Isn't that profound? Let's hear
it for ourel in you're going to be mind
blown.
>> Sometimes a man is tested with an evil
woman. I told you. I told you.
So he feels that I need to live with
this woman and this is the of Allah and
that's it until my life is
so you can actually do any regarding
Yes.
So you can actually do a regarding
whether you should stay with this person
or not.
The same with a man.
So this is a very interesting point that
I've never heard before. He says in the
Quran where Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
speaks of a relationship between a man
and a woman, he's never spoken about.
Amazing. doesn't tell you to have
suffering.
>> There is a general uh command of
patience.
>> You got that point right? There's a
general command of patience, but there's
no command of patience when it comes to
being oppressed in a relationship.
But Allah mentioned rulings when it
comes to this. Okay, do this, do that,
do that.
>> Oh my gosh. I when I was watching I was
getting goosebumps. That is so deep.
Allah does not say if you are going
through A or B with a spouse, be a man
to a woman or a woman to a man. Okay,
there's abuses on both sides. It doesn't
Allah doesn't say to you have patience,
have suffered. There's general sub that
you should have. Okay, there's generally
in life have etc. But Allah gives you
proactive measures like let's go through
these verses one by one guys and tell me
where you see the word sabar the one of
the main verse we know in vers 34 men
are caretakers and protectors of women
because Allah has blessed some of them
over anothers and because of what they
spend their wealth to support the woman
so the righteous women are obedient and
guard the rights and honor of their
husbands in the secret that which Allah
has ordered them to guard okay
protecting your husband's flaws dignity
etc to your family members and to the
public that is the duty of the a woman
because Allah says will cloak to one
another. So a clo does what covers your
shame. That's the reason why Allah says
that that's an obedience of a woman and
and same applies for a man and those
women from whom you fear evil conduct or
disloyalty advise them and I say the so
advise them tell them listen what you're
doing here look I don't accept it
verbally communicate communicate and
this doesn't mean you do it once and
then move to the second no to the best
of your ability warn advise listen I'm
on the verge of divorce or this that etc
you are violating my rights etc whatever
then it says depart from the bed and
then find um isolate them in the bed why
because women like emotional charge they
like these kind words, whatever it is
for that matter. If you see they are
violating your right as a man, yes, you
have a right to what? Move from the bed
to make them understand and realize
without intimacy, without kind of stuff,
affection, love that you are hurt and
you are upset. So they can understand
that if that doesn't work, then Allah
says if they um and then after obviously
words here is distract, but it's not.
It's for example talking about
restraining. Yes, every man will agree
categorically that if it's whoever it
is, even police officers, if a woman is
violent, if a woman is in your face, if
a woman is smashing stuff, you have
every right to restrain them.
Restraining without what? Causing pain,
causing um um uh for example bruises or
whatever is for that matter to restrain
them, hold them. Okay? To stop them.
Everyone will agree that categorically
nobody can come and say in no instance
you can restrain somebody. Okay. Now
it's very interesting because in the
same chapter in chapter 128 which we're
going to come to Allah gives a
prescription to a woman who's been
violated by her husband who's an evil
dua. What to do there? So and then verse
do that. But if they obey, you can now
not seek ways of excuses against them.
Surely Allah is supreme the most high.
And if you for if you for any breach
between both of the men and the wife,
then appoint an arbitrator from his
family and an arbitrator from her
family. If they both desire
reconilation, Allah will make a united
as one stand. Surely is all knowing, all
wise. Okay. So, subhan Allah, you can
see that Allah subhana wa ta'ala is
telling you to take and anyone that
follows the Quran, you'll find
blessings. You run away from this,
you'll see no blessings.
In those verses, did you see anywhere
Allah is saying have Sabar when that
happens have Allah is giving you actions
do A if that doesn't work do B if it
doesn't work do C if it doesn't work get
arbitrators do this so Allah is
proactively telling you what to do now
when we go to surah verse 128 brothers
and sisters it gets really profound you
know why cuz Allah subhana wa tala
advises according to the situation and
the capability so here is of a woman who
is married to an oppressive person yeah
and if a woman fears her husband of ill
treatment of desertion there is no sin
on both of them if they make terms of
peace compromise between themselves
reconciliation or peace is between is
better even though the souls are always
swayed at greediness but if you do and
fear Allah and be pious surely Allah is
all aware of the things that you do okay
so Allah doesn't prescribe to the woman
to tell her oh if he does that then
restrain him or do this okay why because
he acknowledges that a man is stronger a
woman cannot restrain him do you get it
if a man is becoming violent etc you
should get your family members involved
you can get the authority. There's
nothing wrong with this. Getting the
authority involved that this man is
threatening me. Okay? If he's verbally
being abusive, yes, which is also
another form of abuse. Then you can get
your family members involved like the
men in your house cuz a man will keep a
man in check. Okay? Subhan Allah. Now,
when we go to Subhan Allah, another
verse, it says, "Oh prophet, instruct
the believers when you intend to divorce
women, then divorce them with a with
concern for the waiting period and count
it as accurately and fear Allah your
Lord. Do not force them out of their
homes nor should they leave unless they
commit a blatantly blatant misconduct.
These are the limits set by Allah
subhana wa tala. Now what do we notice
and I'm going to go to surah as well
because inah is also really interesting
as well. Are you hearing anywhere that
it says patience have? Yes. No. It's
giving you active measures to take into
place inshallah. Nobody should put up
with abuse. Verbal physical manipulation
gaslighting. Yes. Nobody could. And
abuse comes in different ways. We have
deal we deal with situations of brothers
and sisters subhan Allah where we've
been told that one party agitates the
other party argument say for example a
man psychologically abuses his wife
abuses his wife abuses his wife till she
explodes and has enough shouts scream or
breaks something again it's not the best
thing to do but still does something and
then what do they do recording ah look
what you're doing the manipulation and
narcissism they trigger the wife to the
point she breakin point and then he
takes the camera out or records and
says, "Ah, see what kind smashing
things, insulting me, abusing me." This
kind of person is one of the most
dangerous people that you could be
married to, guys. And he works both
ways. Okay? Now, look at Tal in the name
of Allah, the most merciful, very
merciful. Okay? When you divorce woman,
then divorce them with their waiting and
keep count of their idat fearing Allah
and your do not expel them from their
houses. Let them go unless they commit
an open immorality. These are the limits
set by Allah subhana wa ta'ala. Okay? to
himself. You never know that after that
Allah may make Allah may make some new
situation to happen for the reunion.
Okay? Subhan Allah. You see how Allah
subhana wa ta'ala tells you to take
proactive precautions. But Allah doesn't
tell you to have sabar. Allah doesn't
say if you're going through to have
patience. Allah is telling you to take
actions m meaning what Allahhana knows
best. And if we live by that conduct
brothers and sisters so many marriages
will be saved. So before going to
divorce you have to exhaust all means
for brothers and sisters. This happens
both ways. Both situations we know of
men abusing women, women abusing men.
Okay? Psychologically, physically and in
all different ways. Subhan Allah. But
before you go down that route, you need
to ask yourself a question. Have I
exhausted all necessary means? Have I
done everything in my capability? You
know why? Because once you've done that,
then you can say, you know what? I've
done everything I can. and the the the
the argument say the ingratitude, the
insults. Yes. The verbal abuse, the
physical abuse, the the the the the
person going and cheating on you,
committing dinner. Yes. Okay. Or
flirting with other men or a man going
and cheating. He doesn't give you your
rights. He doesn't give you financial
rights. He's always abusing. He's not a
family man. He doesn't spend time with
his kids. He's always out with shisha
with his friends. Or she's she's
somebody who always goes and back bites
you, slanders you to her family, does
all this kind of stuff. Whatever is for
that matter, you're going to say, you
know what? Allah doesn't tell you to
have. You can. You're rewarded for that.
But Allah doesn't tell you to have
sabar, which is so profound, brothers
and sisters. So, subhan Allah, guys,
when you are going through this, do and
once you've made your decision and you
say, "Okay, I've done everything in my
ability to avert and divert divorce.
Now, I'm going to do." Now, you leave it
to your Lord and you say, "I'm making a
firm decision." has to be done with a
firm decision. You can't be like, "I'm
doing this, but no, no, firm decision. I
have no choice but to leave this
marriage." Yes. And sometimes that is
better for the kids. It is genuinely
guys, you know how I feel about divorce
and you know the whole fiasco I went
through with the whole individuals for
promoting divorce. But no one should be
in a marriage where they've been
physically or sometimes worse
psychologically being abused day in day
out. If someone doesn't know your value,
doesn't know your worth, always putting
you down, always making you feel like
rubbish, going he goes and back bites
his wife to his family members, makes
back someone he should be defending his
wife's honor or she goes to her family
and dishonors you and tells lies and
stuff etc. and dishonors you and talks
about ill of you. Habibi like Malakim
said, look, if you are dealing with a
man like that or a woman like that,
Allah subhana will enrich you. Somebody
out there will know your true value. And
I'm saying this to you, whoever you are.
Don't fall for the sabar. Yes, you'll be
rewarded. No problem. But you don't have
to. Allah has given you the precautions.
You've done that that that that meeting
of a meeting. This that that therapy not
working.
There is nothing wrong with divorce. And
maybe that's the first time you see me
promoting divorce. Brothers and sisters,
in a rational, logical sense. And for
the brothers, I want to give an advice.
If you're married to a woman who is keep
telling you, give me tal, give me tal,
give me tala. With all your respect,
prof is yours. You ask her, you're not
happy in the marriage, I don't have a
problem. You're not happy in the
marriage, you can go get. Okay? The
talak is yours, guys. Do not use or
waste your talak. It is yours. If you're
happy in the marriage and she's not,
tell her to go get and she can follow
the proced.
If you guys have any issues, you can go
to the marriage council. Inshallah, it
was and subhan allah, brothers and
sisters. And inshallah, may Allah
resolve the matters of the um inah and
keep us united because divorce affects
kids. It has a ripple effect. I'm not
condoning but for abusive physical
verbal whatever it is for that matter
you have every right to divorce and like
the sheh said Allah doesn't mention take
proactive actions inshallah if that
doesn't work go your peace with good way
like Allah says in the Quran repel evil
with that which is good and you'll see
the one you have enmity there will be
peace go about it with honor and dignity
and respect inshallah may Allah bless
and peace of you guys till next
We better cat